we're a few days out now
week out from Rainbow month
so another company has gone gay this is
a commercial actually from some years
ago I think it's about two years ago
it's just come back up though it has
made it and gone viral in the wake of
transheiser bush destroying the most
popular beer in America Bud Light
which company is it
this certainly would pain the founder of
this company
Ford Motor Company super duper gay take
it away Ford
commercial opens do not attempt to
recreate or reenact this scene and then
where it should have a warning label you
know the rating for like a movie it's
the pride flag that says progress rated
for progress
here we go we had two mud-soaked Ford
trucks
go baby one looking near than the next
they're off-roading
hard they're driving fast
driving through water
and the oh but then the water washed all
the mud away
and it's gay
the truck has been painted in some pink
with a rainbow on it
which for virtually all of human history
was a sign a symbol given by God of his
Covenant with mankind that he would
never again destroy the world in the
flood now it just symbolizes weird sex
stuff and pride the queen of all sins
and then what happens the rainbow truck
wins
so it's not just that the gay truck the
lgbtq the trans truck
is accepted it's in the race it wins it
has to win
the trans truck has got to win
probably now Ford would not make that
commercial
reason being that Bud Light has been
destroyed I'm not sure Bud Light can
ever recover formerly the most popular
beer in America I think transheiser Bush
destroyed that and they destroyed it in
part because they wanted to stand in the
middle of the road so they couldn't
totally embrace the Dylan Mulvaney beer
can but they also couldn't totally
disavow the Dylan Mulvaney beer can
because the the
audience the consumer base hated the
Dylan Mulvaney transcan but the investor
class the liberal establishment the
media the powers that be they love the
transcan
and they exert a lot of control over the
companies through things like ESG
through things like garm through all of
these International associations and
agreements
which say that if you want access to
advertising if you want access to
Capital you've got to tow this crazy
woke line and so Bud Light has been
wrecked by that
now some companies are trying to dial it
back a Target decided to hire a Satanist
to promote weird trans clothing lines to
all sorts of people there are children's
trans clothing lines there's been
backlash against that now Target
Executives reportedly are scrambling
Ford I assume is going to try to
suppress this commercial it ain't 2021
anymore what changed what changed here
is conservatives were able to Institute
an effective boycott of Bud Light it
just took it a little bit too far and
Frat Boys and construction workers
actually stood up and said no we're not
going to drink this stuff anymore and
furthermore Bud Light it became so
egregious that it became a meme so now
if you're at a bar you say like hey guys
what do you want to drink all right I'm
going to get I'm going to get some
Yingling maybe I'm gonna get some shots
of Jameson and then if you want to make
fun of your buddy you'll say and Johnny
over there I'm gonna get him a Bud Light
yeah take that Johnny I'm making fun of
you I'm calling you effeminate say I
don't want a Bud Light don't give me a
Bud Light man come on and so it's become
a joke and it's very hard to recover
from being a joke I mean that's that's
really brutal same thing probably
happening to Ford here
we've got to keep up that pressure
Matt made this point he articulated it
directly but this has been the point
that has been building for months now
which is
we need to make
that symbol toxic the pride flag symbol
we need to make that toxic
we need to have
companies think twice about it everyone
was talking about the the Dylan Mulvaney
incident as being harmful to the Bud
Light brand that's true but more
importantly it was it was harmful to the
Dylan Mulvaney brand now now other
companies are going to think twice
before sponsoring Dylan Mulvaney because
they don't want to lose six billion
dollars in market cap in two days
that's what we got to do and then once
we make these things culturally toxic or
as we're making these symbols culturally
toxic we've got to bring in the Cavalry
we've got to come back in with more
political force to ban some of this
stuff
to say no we talked about it yesterday
with the sisters of Perpetual Indulgence
this anti-christian drag troupe that is
being honored by the LA Dodgers the LA
Dodgers are either going to exalt the
sisters of Perpetual Indulgence or
they're going to exalt the Carmelite
nuns they're going to exalt regular
normal Christian sisters they're either
going to exalt LGBT ISM pride-ism or
Christianity it's going to have to be
one or the other they're conflicting
moral views and we are going to operate
According to some moral view which one's
it going to be
don't back down now the the progress
that conservatives have made on this
just between 2021 and 2023 the fact that
companies are trying to suppress these
videos now back off them that shows we
are winning keep pushing much much
harder
right now go to puretalk.com Knowles
remember the last time you got a free
phone how to start started out great
didn't it and then came the Hefty
activation fees the four line
requirements and of course that binding
contract Pure Talk is giving you a free
5G Samsung Galaxy phone without the
feeling that you've been duped when you
switch to puretalk's unlimited talk and
text to data plan that comes with a
mobile hotspot you will get a 5G Samsung
Galaxy for free that's right unlimited
everything at a fraction of the price of
Verizon ATT or T-Mobile and here's
another thing you will be on America's
Most Dependable 5G Network how do I know
I'm a customer so make this switch to
Pure Talk the cell phone Wireless
company I'm proud to stand behind
because they offer great service and
they are proud to stand behind our
mission at the daily wire pure talks
us-based customer service team will help
you make the switch in as little as 10
minutes you can even keep your own phone
number it's just a great company great
service go to puretalk.com Knowles for
your free Samsung Galaxy when you sign
up for unlimited talk text and unlimited
data puretalk.com knowlespuretalk
Wireless for Americans by Americans
before we go Kathy hokel she's the
governor of New York Kathy hokel
uh has responded to the migrant crisis
which has been a disaster for Democrat
politicians you see even the liberal
Democrat Eric Adams in New York he's
saying we don't want this migration
crisis stop sending the buses here this
is evil this is awful we can't keep it
up we got to stop it we need Law and
Order here Kathy hokel the Democrat has
come in she's taking the side of the
illegal immigrants
you think about what we have open right
now
I know upstate
I know exactly where it starts too
there are over 5 000 farm jobs 5 000
farm jobs open as we speak
the cows don't wait to be milked the
plants need to be maintained and
harvested in a few months
the props we have more than 5 000 food
service jobs right now
I'm a former waitress I made pizzas
chicken wings weighted tables clean
floors did pots and pans
doesn't take a lot of skill I was 15
years old
those jobs are available
four thousand openings for janitors
cleaners and housekeepers as I mentioned
the jobs for Farm Workers as well
so we're grateful that the Biden
Administration has instituted a new
border
process starting with the suspension of
title 42 on May 11th we all know that
date well and that will allow Asylum
Seekers from other countries to seek
sponsorship and to apply from their home
countries and if they don't they will be
turned back so that is a shift in policy
which we hope will be successful and
mitigate the flow of new arrivals here
we want these people to apply we want
them to come here though we got to have
them do these jobs it's good come on
over here illegal immigrants we want you
what does this mean this means that
Kathy hokel
thinks that her is her bread is buttered
more by the political class than by the
people the people have made their
opinion on illegal immigration clear the
people have been pretty articulate
populism is doing just great okay
a lot of the liberal Elite institutions
are on the run but some politicians are
betting against the people against clear
majorities the vast majority of the
people think transgenderism is insane
the vast majority of the people don't
want their kids being taught critical
race Theory and and weird sex stuff in
schools the vast majority of the people
want to drastically reduce migration so
why are there some politicians who are
still supporting these things
some I guess have firm ideological
beliefs Kathy hokel's not one of those
people why are some of the convenience
Sway in the wind politicians still
supporting the unpopular policies
because they believe that the political
class can do more for them and more
against them than the people can so what
do we have to do we need to show that
people still have some power in this
country we need to wield our pocketbooks
we need to boycott we need to say no to
transheiser Bush we got to say no to
Target we got to say no to and then we
also need to infiltrate that political
class
start wielding the state we've got to
convince the Kathy hokels of the world
the liberal establishment shill Joe
Biden empty suit hack politicians of the
world that there are going to be
consequences too that you can't
totally turn against the people in their
common sense and not face any
consequences you've got to crack that
ruling establishment boy what a clip
that was make sure that you ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel
we'll see you next time